da quando è uscito hunger games abbiamo
desiderato tutti quanti che uscisse il
videogame di hunger games è arrivato ed
è veramente una figata ragazzi prima di
partire seriamente un tuo di cazzeggio
che non so come sono riuscito veramente
a fare balotelli 65 49 tipo hunger games
come fa zero si parte subito a mio
figlio
uno spadone sono un pirata cosa tratta
della dinamite che cazzo è un uomo nudo
velato con l'attacco alla trippa da jack
sparrow
così qualcuno lari loro aiuto viene
nessuno se uno si innamora dinamite ecco
ecco ce ne sono due andiamo andiamo a
cazzo duro
andiamo a cazzo duro a cazzo duro questi
nuotano nell'acqua attenzione con su
sparaco arabo si rifiuta perché ti sei
fatto
oddio oddio attento neanche via vieni
via che c'è la dignità di aster avi
[Musica]
[Risate]
chi aiuterà di una slava che si è
esaltato in km bellissimo chiaro mandato
in aria malissimo e dovendolo rete star
di nicchia per un brand o che al suo
team faccia un tizio malissimo dai
ragazzi cazzeggio finito partiamo col
video serio i ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono farisei mataji sudek all'ing
siamo io e luca che sarebbe no che
funziona tipo hunger games praticamente
ci si mette negli stretti cioè ci sono
mi pare sei distretti stanno già
partendo dragone siamo io e luca appunto
contro tutti gli altri che sono a coppie
dice come hunger games è uguale dato si
parte che siamo rimasti dentro una
scatola
si conosca è figo boom e la madonna
auguri efficace a casa l'altro questo
quel come si chiama
e cosa che ti fa vedere le uccisioni
sulla parete dell'arena fantastico dove
sei tu segui il pallino nel
nella mappa ecco diego di eccoti
[Musica]
hai un accetta c'è qualcosa per me a con
cui si finge ti ho scritto giu ho vinto
io
la cassa si può aprire la madonna ho
trovato un coso per fare il ghiaccio dei
gelati questo guarda visto anche
mettendo la mano dietro per mettere a
fuoco una piccozza stargazer proprio
giallo si rimediano se funziona così
contro di te porco per tv brillo il
birillo vero che ho visti per terra
prese quello che può succedere quando
mangi a lucia via via via via via via
via giarre del fumo che entrato nel muro
chi è che acceso qualcosa di brutti
bastardi di merda
la rara la sun incastrato credito il
fumo via via via via via via
no no bastardi ma mi avrete così
no non ci credo sono marzo morendo è sto
correndo mi sta uccidendo gli altri di
più marca [ __ ]
miu miu miu miu miu miu sono uscito da
gas sono uscito da chiasso 30 di vita
sono mezzo morto
faccio esplodere qua ma che cazzo fai
esplode ma cosa fai quando hai fatto
sbattere sul serio no dai migliaia già
difficile ci manca solo quello guarda
tutti tutti nell'immediato facciamo
tutti al centro adesso del duro faccio
un eco lei è certo siamo tutti inclusi
qui grazie al cazzo che c'è un numero 22
erano armi io sono il piccone la spacca
gli in faccia io provo a girarli dai sei
sentito qualcosa ma errata non me la fa
ancora ha ucciso l'organ freeman carri
che sta succedendo sono nero vedo nero
vedo nero e chiamano chi predica mi dai
bar oa casa uscirà ti picchiano migliori
nella faccia attenzione signore e
signori katniss everdeen aiuto ti sta
spaccando la faccia perché obbliga anche
cattive realta ucciso ricarico ti sento
carico 6 carico dai dai dai dai beni
verso di me che io oddio non c'è un
tizio c'è un tizio averi a salvarmi luca
non riesco a piazza laminam affanculo
soca preciso lancio bastardo e quello
già una lancia cia non ci arriva vieni
luca vieni vieni da mina mandami una
mano accordi con i miei cordin questo si
è dopato corre come non so cosa di
divertimento ma cosa viene adesso direi
che c'è un tizio che vieni tu corri dai
che serve storia di partito milioni già
salvato la vita
squadra capitanata da luca addio così
bravo bravo euro
uccidi nucci di uccidere uccidere come
scappa con il bastardo di mello guarda
lo guardano non è di morire uccidilo
incorna lo vai luca da anche morto è lo
so credo dai morto è morto vivente non
operi ammazzarlo male deve crepare la
vita io l'ho giro di 4 giro cazzola 6
incastonato nelle rocce porca merda dai
look è morto come farlo vedo se venivi
guarda qua e qua e qua no questo qua si
è ricaricato la vita ma cos'è se
ricaricando la vita ma non è vero dai di
michela mazzoni ha detto c'è un altro
tizio sulla destra e uno di qua e mi
piace affatto un club si è più carico di
prima
pronto per lavoro dai ai partiamo
partiamo mi chiami mi ha fatto sfollare
sopra una montagna
adesso mi butto giù e muoio io vedo se
rischio cos'è c'è un tubo all arco ai
l'arco veramente fi wi fi in catene di
arco per favore io io sto ponendo delle
cose che insieme in un anno un senso di
esistere però fatto una fatto una
trappola tu sei sopra la montagna sotto
si sopra allora se dall'altra parte che
ti vedo concretamente però affari
spostarci lo specchio c'è la porta non
ho mica mi mette un anzianità per per
spray ho trovato dello spray per per
pitturare i muri altre diventa c'è
scritto che temporaneamente a circa gli
avversari va bè utile
dai dai dai dai che ritrova de trovo
trovo qualcosa per minare lo so se ho
trovato il budget che culo assurdi simo
ha preso eccoti ciao luca questa inter
proprio bello 6 è elegante sempre nel
momento del bisogno
cosa fai sei scemo poi smettere di fare
il gas oman e che sarebbe il piromane
però degli altri tipico esemplare di
uomo che petta quando non deve
fantastico comunque quanto è figo il
centro alla mappa è bellissimo sembra
tipo e sembra tipo il cosenza sono morti
in quattro è libero divise libero che
entriamo aspetta un tizio morto uguale
ma qualcosa ci sono dei passi sento dei
passi luca sento di passi aspetta fermo
luca sento di passi fermina ti mette
tanto inquietante
mentre mente di me ci sei per 3 2 1 dai
dai che morte morte morte molte volte
molto molto molto
cos'è essere in due e merda attento ha
tentate corso di due qui e morire dai
non muore mai [ __ ] è morto ucciso
ucciso ucciso anche lei vissuto questo
grande l'abbiamo fatta non abbiamo
ucciso due grandissimo per gli europei
che ci hanno accettati sarà un accetta
anche un coltello che aveva prima
comunque quando siamo saliti questi qua
ci stavano facendo il culo perché aveva
piazzato la trappola che ci sono cascati
in pieno
scegli una sorpresa proprio in faccia
tra palliativo spappolati apro la cassa
sotto e ci sei
ho trovato una mazza da baseball michele
va 9 9 27 fantastico figo comunque su
quattro viamo gli avversari che ben
vicino bravo hai un cellulare che ti
aspetta aspetta fermo ce l'hai facebook
facciamo salti beni dai bellissimo 9 lo
feci di questa rai va grandi grazie
anche le frecce allora siamo rimasti in
quattro distretti praticamente se ne
abbiamo c quelli che abbiamo ucciso
avevano fatto fuori tipo 2 persone siamo
mi ha fatto un gran io ti giuro che cio
l'ansia mille cioè bruttissimi te vai
dritto ancora oggi è un giorno sì e uno
no ci sono due mer dando la sua
attenzione su scarpe clarks mancato
cercas tanto stava già è vero che via
via è mica stiamo andando diretti verso
di loro è il livello è sono qua subito
sinistra attenzione non stiamo qua
saremo qua saremo qua saremo qua qua
sopra dovremmo riuscire a fargli il culo
attenzione che la bomba di sa che
esplode se c'è la toccano
eccolo eccolo lo vedi se sono sotto ama
come il ca [ __ ] non dovremmo andare d
arco perché loro ci hanno l'arco
bastard cazzo sapevo che ha fatto
esplodere la bomba arriva arriva rivolto
a 34 nei sei figlio da una mano gliela
devi morire ex5 di tumore
che ragiona solo cercato orca merda come
fanno essere così forti e vabbè quanta
gente
vabbè ma non morivano questi mica li
tiravo le mazzate non arrivano mai ci
sei in tv con un governo come scanditi
dal candidati erano scanditi segreti
come fanno a non vederla 666 così di
fare l'uomo che resiste luca devi farlo
con i residenti garavaldi serve
attenzione che già sta arrivando gente
sta facendo e sta menando tra di loro
magari vito alla fine dell'ultimo
tocchetto e vinci no ad entrare da vista
da rialzi certa gente con rick beni
aerei e tranquillo tranquillo se
esistano meno antoni loro alla fine di
mani sono tubi voci pensi mite vinci tu
sei l'orgoglio del distretto 41 se vince
le spalle delle guardo io e vai
tranquillo c'è qualcuno là
eccolo lì come carri ma come fanno
esserci liste si stanno menando
dall'altra particolari carica ricarica
si fermi caf ai giochi
cosa fai sei falso un pazzo è la pistola
ma quanta gente è rimasta viva oddio 312
allora ci sono anche quelli sopra sono i
nostri pochissimi iniziale ricetta dai
15 ai cinque avversari incameramento
sembra insurgent della mannaia quanto fa
8 24 è forte però il java in secondo me
più forte perché essendo lontano per è
ancora un po freddo a chi lione davanti
davanti è quanta gente mi chiama che si
mi aspettavano da me allora venite qua
bastardi a 22
ti faccio colori faccio culo bella
scopre di partecipi al culo seri da solo
mi chiedi stuprava anche alla famiglia
aveva cambiato sempre in due
non me li faccio il t2 questo è nudo chi
è stato questo fai che bard è
sufficiente questa si è alzata lontani
io donna io taser che il cazzo volete
ora questo nome lo faccio sette le tv
ma come questo qui che fai kebab le mine
picchia la mannaia guarda lì dietro due
colti madonna si riusciva a curarmi e la
nuova affanculo vasta se riuscirò a
curarmi la morti ma con che faccia mi ha
ucciso che faccio certo uomo di ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto era un
tentativo visto che non sapevamo neanche
come giocare non aveva fatto nessuna
partita di prova quindi volevo iniziare
proprio registrando con voi per
scoprirlo insieme diciamo spero che ai
video vi sia piaciuto va solito seguito
è piaciuta sotto un commento è un mi
piace anche a casini facebook e come un
video trascrizione se volessi discreti
ci vediamo al prossimo vito 100 ragazzi
[Musica]